مثنى يطلب عرض افلام في دور السينما عن
حرب اوكرانيا الاسرائيليه وتحقق في نسيان
مجنده ببلده فلسطينيه
اهلا بكم
نبدا من روسيا حيث طلب الرئيس
حول الحرب في اوكرانيا وفي رساله تم نشرها
على موقع طلبات الرئاسه الروسيه طلبت من
وزاره الثقافه تقديمه مقترحات لضمان عرض
افلام وثائقيه وطنيه في دور السينما حول
مواضيعها تتعلق بالعمليه العسكريه الخاصه
في اوكرانيا
الجديده والفاشيه الجديده وكانت موسكو
وصفات عملياتها في اوكرانيا
2022 بانها تهدف الى النازيه
لقي مقطع فيديو ونشره فلسطينيه على
السوشيال ميديا انتشارا واسعا اذا يظهر
المقطع مجنده اسرائيليه تسير بمفردها في
ترقب وحذر شديدين داخل بلده جنوب مدينه
رام الله وسط الضفه الغربيه في المقابل
اعلنت شرطه حرس الحدود الاسرائيليه فتح
تحقيق فوريه حول نسيان احدى مجنداتها داخل
بلده الرام الفلسطينيه في نهايه عمليه
انتقلت خلالها ثلاثه فلسطينيين مشيره في
بيان لاحقا الى ان التحقيق الاولي افاد
بان قوه من الشرطه كانت قريبه من المجنده
وعلى تواصل البصري معها
[موسيقى]
الى مصر هذه المره حيث القت الاجهزه
الامنيه القبض على بلوجر شهيره تدعى اسراء
محبه مع صاحب محل ملابس
وبحوزتهما كميه من مخدرات داخل شقه في
منطقه التجمع الخامس بالقاهره وسائل اعلام
فادت بان الشرطه تستهدفت الشقه السكنيه
المستاجره وضبطت البلوجر اسراء مع صديقها
وبحوزتهما كلغرامان من الحشيش اضافه الى
500 غرام من الهيروين فيما اضافته وزاره
الداخليه ان اسراء الاوضحت ان اسراء
وشريها اعترف بحيازاتهما للمواد المخدره
المضبوطه بقصد التجاره وتم ضبطها واتخاذ
الاجراءات القانونيه حيالها
بعد تداول انباء تحدثت عن توتر العلاقه
بين جورجينا رودريغيز والنجم البرتغاليه
كريستيانو رونالدو المنضم حديثا لصفوف
نادي النصر السعودي نفذ جورجينا تلك
الانباء بصوره عبر حسابها في تويتر وقالت
في تعليقها على تلك الصوره التي نشرتها
لرونالدو بقميص النصر اثناء حفل تقديمه في
الرياض امس يبدا فصل جديد مره اخرى يظهر
من هو الافضل في العالم انا فخوره فيما
قال ناشطون على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ان منشور جورجينا اتى ليطحضت كل ما تم
تداوله مؤخرا عن علاقتها المتوتره بالنجم
البرتغالي
[موسيقى]
وفي خبرينا الاخيره نهالت الانتقادات
وعبارات
على السويسري جيانين فانتينو رئيس الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم فيفا عقب التقاط صوره
السلفي قرب النعش جثمان اسطوره كره القدم
بيليه في سانتوس وفي اول رد له قال
انفنتينو انستغرام انه يشعر والحيره بعد
تعرضه للانتقاد بسبب السلفي
طلبوا منه التقاط صوره سيلفي لهم جميعا
لكنهم لم يعرفوا كيفيه فعل ذلك ليقرر
مساعدتهم بالتقاط الصوره التي اثارت جدلا
واسعا لاحقا
[موسيقى]